this episode was made in collaboration
with you gopnik be sure to check out
their video after this
[Music]
if you were born at any point after the
80s odds are the entirety of your lived
experience has been one of crisis
for people my age our formative years
were filled with the consequences of u.s
activity
our earliest memories include 911 and
the invasion of iraq under false
pretenses
then we had the 2008 housing crash the
realization that climate change was
nearing a point of no return
the acceleration of suicidal
deregulation and privatization
which has left our infrastructure weak
and fragile the skyrocketing cost of
tuition
saddling young people who were told
college was the only way to succeed
with insurmountable debt and
increasingly worthless degrees
we've seen the birth and rapid rise of
the gig economy relegating huge portions
of the population to precarity and
poverty
and of course we've watched our coveted
response become the worst in the world
despite having advanced knowledge of the
danger and plenty of resources to handle
the situation appropriately
for millennials and younger generations
there's no such thing as
the good old days we never experienced
them we'll cover that topic more
thoroughly in a future video
but in this week's episode we're going
to examine why the u.s seems to be
completely incapable of handling crises
now this video could easily be over an
hour long
the past few decades have seen an
alarming acceleration in crisis
mismanagement
and it would take way too long to cover
them all we're just going to focus on a
handful of them
before we get to the big ones let's
start with a very american problem
obesity at first glance you wouldn't
necessarily think to call obesity a
crisis
but when you look at the numbers in the
u.s things become a bit more grim
as of 2018 42.4 percent of all american
adults were obese
that number increased drastically
between 2000 and 2018
shooting up by nearly 12 while severe
obesity nearly doubled from 4.7
to 9.2 percent obesity among children is
also a big problem
of children between the ages of 2 and 19
nearly 1 in 5
are obese now obesity doesn't just mean
you're a bit overweight
it's a serious health condition and it
comes with a whole slew of problems
heart disease stroke type 2 diabetes and
increased susceptibility to certain
types of cancer
not to mention a lower quality of life
and shorter average lifespan
the fact that nearly half of american
adults are obese should be a huge red
flag according to one study conducted in
2008
the estimated annual medical cost of
obesity in the u.s was a staggering 147
billion dollars
and judging by the increased prevalence
of obesity in the years since
we can only assume that cost has risen
dramatically obesity causes nearly one
in five deaths in the u.s
that's a crisis and it's not talked
about nearly enough
now some people will simply tell those
suffering from obesity to eat better
and that's not unreasonable but the
roots of the crisis go far beyond
individual responsibility
back in the 50s president eisenhower had
a heart attack
which sparked a scientific debate over
the causes of obesity which was known to
cause heart disease
there were two main schools of thought
one led by british physiologist and
nutritionist john yudkin
and the other by ancel keyes an american
physiologist
yud can believe that obesity was mainly
caused by sugar and keys thought it was
caused by fat
eventually it became apparent that
judkin was correct sugar was the culprit
behind the condition
but wait if we identified the cause all
the way back in the 50s
why is the problem so much worse today
well the sugar industry didn't take
kindly to the scientific findings
they funded disinformation campaigns and
lobbied the government to support the
low-fat diet initiative in an attempt to
maintain their profits
this not only helped them keep their
current profits it also drastically
increased them because in order to make
low-fat foods appealing to an american
palette
manufacturers had to add more sugar so
the result of a scientific study clearly
linking sugar to obesity was not the
reduction of sugar in our diets
but a massive disinformation campaign
that ended up increasing the amount of
sugar in our foods
thereby worsening the very problem we
wanted to solve
keep this result in mind because you'll
begin to notice a pattern
so what have we done to combat obesity
in the decades since the initial studies
well not much some states have tried to
implement sugar taxes
but on the whole we haven't even made a
dent in the crisis
it's only getting worse in the case of
obesity not only have we failed to
handle it
our capitalist system caused it a giant
industry wanted to keep making money
so they threw the american people under
the bus and we've been dealing with the
same problem for well over half a
century now
let's move on to one of the big crises
one that affects not only the us
but the entire world climate change
whether you think humans are influencing
the climate change or not
the data is clear our climate is
changing dramatically and
rapidly sea ice is melting at
unprecedented rates causing a rise in
sea level
the oceans are becoming more acidic
leading to the annihilation of coral
reefs
violent weather events have become far
more common and we're beginning to see
thousand-year storms droughts and floods
every few years
thousands of species are at risk of
extinction disease is able to spread
farther and faster thanks to longer warm
seasons
and entire regions are becoming
unlivable in early 2020 i helped shoot a
documentary called the final years of
madro
which documented the effects of sea
level rise in the marshall islands
i saw firsthand what will happen to the
world's coastal regions and islands
they're going underwater their
populations will have to evacuate or be
destroyed
since the us likes to think of itself as
the leader of the world surely we're at
the forefront of climate change
mitigation right
well no in fact we're not even close
the united states is one of the few
places on earth where elected officials
openly deny the existence of climate
change
the climate doesn't care whether you're
a democrat or a republican
or to quote a certain internet person
facts don't care about your feelings
we have the facts climate change is
happening so why do our politicians
even the ones who acknowledge the crisis
refuse to address the problem
you won't be surprised to learn that
once again corporate interests stand in
the way
in order to understand the present
situation let's take a trip back to the
late 70s
towards the end of the decade and into
the 80s exxon was at the forefront of
climate research
not because they particularly cared
about the planet but because they wanted
to understand the effects of the
changing climate to better position
themselves against the competition in
the future
for example when they began drilling in
the beaufort sea in the canadian arctic
exxon scientists wondered whether the
increased co2 emissions would warm the
region enough to make the voyage and
extraction less treacherous
and therefore more profitable with goals
like these in mind
exxon began conducting some of the most
thorough climate change studies to date
between 1986 and 1992 the company used
and developed cutting-edge models to
understand the effects of co2 and other
greenhouse gases on the climate
accumulating incredibly valuable data to
use the beaufort c example again
exxon scientists determined that should
atmospheric co2 concentration double and
they predicted it would by 2050
the region's open water season would
lengthen from two months to three
possibly even five they underestimated
how quickly atmospheric co2 would
accumulate
but they were exactly correct about the
lengthening of the beaufort open water
season
and this is just one example their
models also accurately predicted rising
temperatures dramatic weather
severe ice loss droughts floods and all
manner of other consequences to their
actions
and all of this was collected not with
the intention of curbing the fallout
but of understanding how they could best
position themselves to take advantage of
the changing climate
as discourse around climate change
heated up so to speak exxon was in a
position to do some real good
they had some of the best data available
and it would have made a huge difference
in understanding how best to mitigate
the consequences of climate fallout
instead they chose to do the same thing
the sugar industry did
they funded opposition groups launched
disinformation campaigns
and buried their own internal studies so
that the public would never learn what
they had discovered
for decades exxon and other oil and gas
giants paid huge sums of money to
suppress the facts and lobby politicians
to sow confusion
and distrust of established science it
wasn't until the mid-2000s that exxon
finally distanced themselves from some
of the more outspoken climate denial
groups
like the competitive enterprise
institute but to this day they play a
major role in subverting the effort to
do anything at all about climate change
and they continue to fund
climate-denying politicians who help
secure oil and gas profits
to the detriment of the entire human
race exxon denies this of course
but if you'd like to see the evidence
for yourself i've left links to their
internal documents and to an
investigative study on the matter in the
description
today thanks in no small part to the
greed of fossil fuel companies
we are years behind where we should be
when it comes to mitigating climate
fallout
heck in the u.s we can't even agree it's
happening at all so again
just like with the obesity crisis we're
not only incapable of solving the
problem
our capitalist system created the
problem let's move on to our final big
crisis
coronavirus we're now right around the
one year mark for when americans really
began to realize just how serious the
problem was
in the past year over 500 000 americans
have died of kovid
we've had more cases and more deaths
than anywhere else on earth
this is despite the fact that we have
almost limitless resources to spend on
overcoming crises like this one
if we're really the greatest country on
earth why has our coronavirus response
been one of
if not the worst in the world as always
to better understand the situation
we need to rewind a bit when kovid first
came to the states the official response
as with climate change was denial it
immediately became a political issue
if trump were to take the necessary
measures to ensure the public's safety
he believed he would have tanked his
approval rating and his economic numbers
unsurprisingly both tanked anyway after
americans started dropping like flies
but the story of our kovid response is
not just about politics
a disease outbreak is perhaps the only
thing able to reveal all the little
cracks in the country's armor at the
same time
conservatives declared we didn't want to
go into lockdown because that was
government overreach
a rallying cry taken up by conservative
voters of course the politicians and
wealthy business moguls didn't really
care about government overreach
they just wanted to make sure american
workers kept working so the executives
could maintain their profits
once it became apparent that we would
have to enforce some kind of lockdown
things started to snowball many american
businesses operate on razor thin margins
to reduce costs and maximize profits
so when they lost business they
immediately had to lay off their workers
in order to weather the storm
since american health care is tied to
employment those millions of workers
suddenly found themselves without a
paycheck or
access to medical care if they became
sick you know something that happens
quite often in a pandemic
since our country lacks even the barest
provisions for the unemployed
millions of households soon ran out of
money they couldn't pay rent
landlords are some of those people who
run dangerously lean operations
relying on their tenant's rent checks to
pay off their properties they begin to
evict their tenants
over the next few months millions of
americans contract kovid
and our bizarre obsession with freedom
led many to refuse to wear a mask
a tiny simple piece of cloth that's
proven to be effective in helping
prevent the spread of disease
our case numbers exploded becoming the
worst in the world
hospitals were overrun we had to start
digging mass graves
the people who could get a hospital bed
could no longer afford the medical bills
because they didn't have insurance
hundreds of thousands of people went
into tremendous debt because the u.s
is the only developed country not to
have some form of universal health
care while the country was falling apart
democrats and republicans alike
continued to make the situation worse
republicans railed against mass mandates
and asserted that the disease was no
worse than the flu
or that it was a chinese hoax and the
democrats paid lip service to the
science but lied about how well they
were handling their city's outbreaks
but the politicians are not the only
ones to blame the general public must
bear some of the shame as well
despite mountains of data on both how
dangerous the disease is and how other
countries have been able to contain it
americans flock to beaches parties
restaurants and the super bowl
because damn it it's my god-given right
as an american our bull-headed
stubbornness and genocidal selfishness
has contributed countless bodies to the
pile
how many of you watching have lost a
loved one to covid
their death was completely avoidable
take countries like vietnam or new
zealand
these places absolutely destroyed the
virus despite vietnam's proximity to
china
kovid rolls in and they're like nope not
gonna let this happen
they implement strict lockdown measures
social distancing and contact tracing
immediately
would you like to see their coveted
stats compared to ours here you go
pretty stark difference to those of you
who feel the need to say well they have
a smaller population
take a look at the per capita death rate
vietnam has about a third of the u.s
population
so we would assume that they'd have a
third the number of deaths right
not even close vietnam a country with a
gdp of 261 billion dollars
absolutely destroyed the us a country
with a gdp of 20 trillion dollars
in terms of coveted response
effectiveness of course you won't hear
about this
it's not the first time the us has
decided not to talk about being beaten
by the vietnamese
so yes by all metrics the us coronavirus
response has been among the worst in the
world
quite possibly the worst considering the
resources we have at our disposal
this perfect storm of capitalist
fragility laid bare the failures of the
most powerful nation on earth
the country like so many of its
businesses operates on the tiniest of
margins
if we can save a single dollar by not
having enough hospital beds or ppe for
an emergency
we're gonna do it if we can make more
money by extorting our citizens when
they need to go to the doctor
we're gonna do it social safety nets
cost money so they're out of the
question
so are maternity leave benefits pensions
and fair wages
every single aspect of our modern life
is meticulously crafted to yield
ever-increasing profits
and the tiniest grain of sand in the
gears of this machine completely
destroys our fragile equilibrium
we are not equipped to handle crises
because crisis management isn't
profitable
we just ignore our problems and hope
things work out this is fine for those
at the top
they have the wealth to weather a
year-long crisis 99
of americans do not what is it going to
take to get the people of this country
to realize that not only can we not
handle crises
our predatory capitalist system actively
causes the crisis
capitalism cannot and will not solve the
problems it creates
we have a homelessness crisis at the
same time as an excess of housing
why housing the homeless isn't
profitable we maintain low-level wars
for decades at tremendous cost of human
life
why because war is profitable the
military-industrial complex is one of
our biggest industries
it's why we ignore humanitarian crises
like the war in yemen
the united states arms the people
responsible for the massacre
what happens when the next crisis is
worse how many americans have to die
before we realize that capitalism is
destroying us
we already have another ticking time
bomb on the horizon each successive
generation is less well-off than the
previous one
older generations those who experience
the final years of comfort for the
average american worker are dying off
younger people don't have the buying
power their parents and grandparents did
we're having fewer children mostly
because we can't afford to raise
children
fewer children means fewer people to
grow up and buy things
what happens when a country built on
consumerism runs out of people to buy
those products
consumption falls off a cliff gdp
plummets businesses flee to other
countries
poverty skyrockets and the american
empire implodes
it's not some innate characteristic of
the us that makes us incapable of
handling crises
any country with a system as
hyper-capitalist as ours would suffer
similarly poor performance
if you look around the world there are
plenty of mostly capitalist countries
that handle the pandemic much better
than the us
what's the difference they have their
guard rails intact
social safety nets robust unemployment
assistance universal healthcare
their citizens are more secure their
business is less predatory
they haven't deregulated and privatized
their countries into oblivion
in america we've removed those
guardrails and stepped on the gas
after all the biggest profits are right
at the edge of the cliff
capitalism is why we can't handle crises
if you're familiar with my channel you
know that my perspective is very
us-centric
it's what i know best if you'd like to
get a more global perspective on this
topic
make sure to check out ugopnik's video
next it's a fantastic companion piece to
this video
if you enjoyed this episode consider
dropping a like if you hated it a thumbs
down
you can check out my previous episodes
by clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week